Welcome back everyone this will be my doctor
strange two post credit scene video there's a
whole bunch of marvel easter eggs so we'll break
it down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos and careful
for spoilers for the movie if you have not seen
it yet because we're literally talking about the
post-credits scenes and the ending of the movie
so at the end of the movie a remorseful scarlet
witch winds up destroying the darkhold temple
at mount wundagor which is a big call back to her
original comic book origin story at mount wundagor
the high evolutionary was a big part of that we'll
probably see him during guardians of the galaxy 3
the temple itself is ancient and was built by
cthon himself the darkhold book was basically
just transcribed from the writings all around the
temple in the comics cthon is the god of chaos
he's the person who gave scarlet witch or chaos
magic when she was born he's one of the ancient
elder gods of the mcu that was expelled from the
main dimension a long time ago and has been trying
to break back in ever since and tries to back
door use scarlet witch in the dark hole to do that
all those references to her becoming the scarlet
witch and ruling over the multiverse in the movie
were meant to be a sly reference to that it
was all about cathodon trying to use her to
take over the entire multiverse the going rule
as you would expect is that if you don't see a
body they're not dead so that means that scarlet
witch is not dead she'll definitely come back at
some point there are rumors they're going to do a
solo movie for her that's when they would actually
do the god of chaos kathan the monsters that are
guarding the temple that actually obey her will
are designed to look kind of like catholic
so their faces look a little bit like his
but then after they go back to comartaj america
chavez starts training as a sorcerer she starts
learning basic magic skills how to control her
powers she jokes about how hard it is to open
portals with the sling rings it's meant to be a
big callback to the first doctor strange movie
with him not being able to open the portals
right away doctor strange congratulates her
and says that she'll find her parents eventually
and show them how much she's grown that's just
sort of establishing her arc in the mcu eventually
in some future projects she will find her parents
doctor strange has a conversation with wong about
finding true happiness like are you actually happy
that's just sort of setting him on the next phase
of his path like actually finding true happiness
he returns to the new york sanctum fixes the
watch that mcu christine palmer gave to him same
watch that he used to open the 838 universe the
illuminati dr strange's waypoint to the book of
the vishanti that's meant to put a bow on his arc
during this particular movie and during spiderman
no way home just to show how much he's learned
about not messing with things because it's meant
to be kind of ironic too because he fixes the
watch like he's fixing the time piece as if he's
fixing reality but they didn't really fix that
much during the film it's just gonna get even more
broken as we head to secret wars with more and
more incursions happening he walks down the street
in his plane clothes and as he's crossing the
street he stumbles over in pain clutching himself
and there's this big danny elfman music cue that's
just like the music cues during the sinister
strange battle where he clutches himself in a
third eye just like sinister strange's emerges
on his forehead the reason why this happened
is because he was corrupted by the dark hole
the same way sinister strange was just by reading
from it using it in different ways that's also why
they use the similar music cue to the sinister
strange battle so that you kind of remember
that it is one of the things that the souls of the
damned that we saw later in the film were yelling
at him about when he started using the dark hole
to dreamwalk across universes into the dead body
of defender strange they said what he was doing
was forbidden and he'd suffer eternal consequences
that was sending up a couple different things
that there were actual souls of the damned from
an alternate hell-like dimension kind of like
we learned on moon knight they explained how the
afterlife is just a bunch of alternate dimensions
that your soul your life essence travel to after
death and the particular dimension that it goes to
is just dependent on who you were what your belief
system was and whether or not you had some sort of
cosmic level contract with another really powerful
entity like the mcu gods of different pantheons
these particular souls that seem like they're
bound to the darkhold and chaos magic in some way
are from another hell-like dimension where the
marvel fear lords would rule did you know there's
an entire chapter devoted to you in the dark hole
that's the book of the damned like i said
the movie did specifically reference kathon
the god of chaos in a big way he
could be involved with that part too
but the other thing that the souls of the dan
were foreshadowing was at the end of the movie
where he literally suffers the consequences just
like sinister strange suffered the consequences
performing the darkhold spells reading from the
book it corrupted him thus he gets the third eye
and begins to lose his humanity as he becomes
more powerful this is also a big call back to
the first doctor strange movie in the mcu version
of the origin story for their version of dormammu
so it's no coincidence that they literally go
to dor mamu's dark dimension at the end of the
post-credits scene but in that first post credit
scene surprisingly charlize theron who's been
rumored to show up in marvel movies for a long
time now shows up as clea from the comics walks up
to him all pissed off saying that he just caused
the new incursion and they're going to fix it
in the funny way they play this that he gets all
excited like hell yeah let's do this while he
has the full-on third eye in his forehead showing
and clea doesn't have any kind of reaction to it
at all like she doesn't even look at the third eye
as if it's no big deal she uses a magical artifact
to tear open a multiverse portal to dormammu's
dark dimension or because we're talking about
incursions here different universes colliding
they could just say dormammu lives in an alternate
universe instead of an alternate dimension this is
part of a bigger question that they raise in a lot
of these recent marvel phase 4 movies and disney
plus series is whether or not they're using the
term alternate universes alternate timelines and
alternate dimensions as interchangeable things
when really they're like completely different
concepts usually marvel tries to simplify
everything so that like your grandma could go
to see the movie and understand what's going on
so that's why i think they might actually just be
simplifying a lot of these really cosmic concepts
because a lot of people will be wondering if
the incursions have something to do with the
kang multiverse war which is each of the kings
in the multiverse trying to fight other timeline
versions of kang and make their own timeline
supreme they're basically trying to destroy
alternate timelines and even though the concept
of an alternate timeline is a little bit different
when you talk about alternate universes what the
different versions of kang are doing fighting
this multiverse war is basically what happens
during time runs out with the illuminati trying
to destroy alternate versions of earth to prevent
them from destroying their earth and recently in
an interview kevin feige also clarified that
the loki one season finale with he who remains
dying and leading to infinite timelines rising
up the kang multiverse war starting over again
was supposed to set up the events of spider-man no
way home and doctor strange multiverse of madness
with the multiverse being able to go crazy in
the first place just to be clear the multiverse
did exist before the events of loki season 1
because dr strange himself goes on a tour of the
multiverse when the ancient one is talking to him
at the beginning the first doctor strange movie
and that was that long before the events
of loki and sylvie meeting he who remains
but the whole idea with the incursions starting
and happening more and more frequently is that
they are doing a time runs out storyline across
all of marvel phase four marvel phase five
whenever they decide to do this big secret war
situation because when time runs out hopefully
they'll introduce a version of doctor doom at some
point everybody kind of waiting for that they'll
take the remnants of those remaining universes
combine them into a single universe to form a
cohesive planet and that'll be their battle world
scenario with the many many alternate versions of
the characters many different variants of all
the biggest characters they could call it an
avengers movie or they could just call it secret
wars and it would be fine the reason why i said
them going to fix the incursion indoor mammoths
universe is a big callback to the first doctor
strange movie in the creation of mcu dormammu
is because dormammu's origin story plays a lot
like sinister strange's origin story in what's
currently happening to mcu doctor strange they
start out as a normal person but then they amass
more and more power becoming more and more evil
more and more corrupted in fact during the concept
phase they originally envisioned that mcu dormammu
would be kind of like a dark visage looking
version of mcu doctor strange that's why benedict
cumberbatch is the voice of dormammu he's doing
his husky dragon voice from the hobbit when he
does mcu dormammu but it is benedict cumberbatch
it's just that it took him to the second movie to
pay that off like look if you continue to get more
powerful you're only going to get worse and worse
and worse until you become kind of like dormammu
also them going to stop the incursion in the dark
dimension kind of makes it seem like they're going
to save mcu dormammu in that post-credit scene
the second post-credits scene is just a funny tag
scene of bruce campbell's pizza ball seller from
earlier in the film having dr strange's spell
wear off and then he laughs turns to camera
breaking the fourth wall saying it's finally over
kind of laughing at us the audience it's meant to
be a reference to like three different things it's
a deadpool style fourth ball break scarlet witch
kind of breaks the fourth wall earlier in the film
but not in the same way that bruce campbell does
at the end of the film like she doesn't speak
directly the audience he just looks directly
into the camera it us the audience the reason why
bruce campbell doing it is like deadpool doing it
is because he acknowledges that he's a fictional
character in a movie making fun of their own
movie like ha ha the movie is finally over it's
also meant to be a reference to doctor strange's
spell finally being over in the context of the
story like yay i'm not punching myself anymore
and lastly it's also meant to be a big sam raimi
evil dead easter egg to ash's evil hand that was
possessed sam raimi includes other sam raimi
easter eggs in his films all the time like this
during the evil dead series ash's hand becomes
possessed and keeps attacking him like we saw
during this film when doctor strange enchanted
it he chops it off during that film to try and
stop it that's where his chainsaw hand came from
and he's been doing this evil dead series he's
been reprising the role of ash in all these
different movies all these years so he's just
kind of laughing saying haha it's finally finally
over i'm sure there's a thousand more questions
about what was going on during the post-credits
scenes everything they're setting up the living
tributal all the big cosmic characters my next
big video will be my full breakdown in easter
eggs for the entire film so that's where i'll talk
about a lot of that stuff everyone click here for
my full review of the movie and click here for my
full moon knight episode 6 finale video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!